Ever since I was a kid
I never really fit in
no one understands me.
Hey Red, how are ya?
Oh, I'm horrible.
Mister Rare?
There seems to be a recurring issue here
Don't look Bobby, the anger might be contagious.
He started it.
Hurry! Something's comming.
Greetings!
I am a pig!
What's a pig?
Unbelivable!
...not workin' not workin'...
Uh! Where are we going?
...not workin'...
"Sigh" - We practiced this a hundred times.
Give it to me!
We're gonna come in again.
These pigsurias are weird, am I right?!
I don't trust them!
I think they're up to something!
Your opinion is not needed!
Is that what I think it is?
Excuse me! Those are fragile, right,
not yours!
You note our guests here are welcome!
And you're not asking basic questions!
Doesn't anyone see whats going on here??
The hole world is in danger!
And it's up to us, to stop 'em.
The pigs are stealing our eggs!!
Set sail for piggy-island.
You tried to tell us, but we didn't listen
What do we do now?
THAT is where they went
and so THAT is where we're going.
We're gonna get those eggs back. Come on!
We're birds. We're descendants from dinosaurs.
We're not supposed to be nice
Hooooly Mooolly!
Yeah, point made.
FIRE!
That guy again.
TAKE THAT PORKER!
Well how about that
she can shoot fireballs out of her butt.
Call in the piggy-airforce!
Ey, he's comming back.
Aaaah - Did we win?
Remember: the goal is the Castle. Get to the Castle!
Am I get a running staaaaaaart...
... I wasn't reeeeady!!!!
Jock! Is that you?
This is a house of Horror.